After 19 years, they're back. Frankie Munes, Brian Cranston, and the rest of the family reunite in Malcolm in the middle, life's still unfair. After 10 years avoiding them, Hal and lowest demand Malcolm be at their anniversary party, pulling him straight back into their chaos. Malcolm in the middle, life's still unfair. A special four-part event, streaming April 10th on Hulu on Disney Plus. The Gionin' Shoja bells ringed the passing of all things. twin salle trees white in full flower declare the great man's certain fall
19年后，他们回来了。弗兰基·穆尼兹、布莱恩·科兰斯顿以及其他家庭成员在《马尔柯姆的一家》中重聚，生活依然不公。在躲避了他们10年后，哈尔和洛伊丝要求马尔柯姆参加他们的周年纪念派对，直接将他拉回了混乱之中。《马尔柯姆的一家》，生活依然不公。四集特别节目，4月10日起在Disney Plus的Hulu频道上线。祇园精舍的钟声，敲响了世间万物无常的真谛；双沙罗树洁白的花朵，宣告了伟人终将陨落的宿命。
the arrogant do not long endure they are like a dream one night in spring the bold and brave perish in the end they are as dust before the wind so those are perhaps the most celebrated lines in all of japanese literature they will strike a chord surely with all of our listeners they are the classic evocation of the buddhist that all things will and must pass. And today on the rest is history, many things will be as dust before the wind, the lives of formidable and brave warriors, the power of mighty dynasties, and the peace and prosperity and security that for many years had reigned in Kyoto, the great imperial capital of Japan. And Tom, these events, we know about them because they're described
傲慢者终难长久，他们如春夜梦一场；勇猛者终将消亡，他们如风前尘埃。这或许是日本文学中最著名的诗句，它们定能引起我们所有听众的共鸣。这是对佛教“万物皆有终结，万物必将消逝”这一思想的经典诠释。今天在《历史的余味》节目中，许多事物都将如风前尘埃：那些强大而勇敢的武士的生命，那些显赫王朝的权力，以及多年来统治着日本伟大帝都京都的和平、繁荣与安宁。汤姆，我们之所以了解这些事件，是因为它们被记载在……
in the book of the Heike, which is the great war epic, the Iliad of medieval Japan, isn't it? Yes, and those lines you quoted are from its opening, and it's in the translation by Royal Tyler for Penguin Classics. And it's a tremendous read. So, Dominic, we met the Heiker or the Tyra, as they are better known, in the first episode of this, our epic series on The Rise of the Sears. samurai, and just to remind listeners about who the hiker or the Tyra, as we'll be calling them, who they are. They are an aristocratic dynasty that had first emerged in Japan in the early 9th century, and they're descended from a kind of whole crowd of princes who had become surplus to imperial requirements. They'd also much too expensive to maintain, and so they'd been deprived of their
《平家物语》中，那是伟大的战争史诗，是中世纪日本的《伊利亚特》，对吧？是的，你引用的那些诗句出自它的开篇，译者是企鹅经典丛书的罗伊·泰勒。这是一部非常棒的作品。多米尼克，我们在关于“武士崛起”这一史诗系列的第一集中介绍了平家，也就是平氏。为了提醒听众平家或平氏（我们将这样称呼他们）是谁：他们是一个贵族王朝，最早于9世纪初在日本兴起，他们是一群因不再被皇室需要而沦为“多余”的皇子们的后裔。他们维持生活的费用太高，因此被剥夺了……
princely status. They'd been given this surname of Tyra. And so they had, effectively been banished from the silken court of Kyoto with its love of calligraphy and perfumes and cherry blossom. And they've gone off to the much rougher and wilder northeastern reaches of Honshu, the kind of the main island of Japan. And they'd make great names for themselves there. And these northeastern reaches of Japan in the early Middle Ages, this is where people lived who were viewed by the Japanese as barbarians.
皇族身份。他们被赐予了“平”这个姓氏。于是，他们实际上被逐出了京都那充满书法、香气和樱花的丝绸宫廷。他们前往了本州岛（日本主岛）更粗犷、更荒凉的东北地区。他们在那里闯出了名堂。在中世纪早期，日本的这些东北地区，居住着被日本人视为“蛮族”的人。
And they'd only just been subdued, brought under the rule of, the emperor in Kyoto. And so there's still very much a kind of feel of a frontier zone. And as a result of this, the Tyra, even though they are descended from emperors, they're not as into writing poetry, I think it's fair to say, as the courtiers and the great lords who are back in Kyoto. Although they do still love a poem, as we will see. And we said how back in the court in Kyoto, warriors are despised. To be a fighter is to be seen as someone who is thuggish and uncultured. But of course, this is not the case beyond the mountains that lie east of Kyoto. That attitude is a luxury, isn't it? It's a luxury that comes with comforts and security.
他们才刚刚被征服，被纳入京都天皇的统治之下。因此，那里依然有一种边境地带的感觉。结果，平氏虽然是天皇的后裔，但我想说，他们并不像京都的朝臣和权贵那样热衷于写诗。尽管正如我们将要看到的，他们依然喜爱诗歌。我们曾提到，在京都宫廷中，武士是受鄙视的。成为一名战士被视为粗鲁和缺乏教养。但当然，在京都以东的山脉之外，情况并非如此。那种态度是一种奢侈，不是吗？那是一种伴随着舒适和安全而来的奢侈。
Completely. And there, for centuries now, it has been the custom for an entire order of men. So they might be low-ranking nobles, they might be upwardly mobile peasants. to be raised from childhood in the saddle, shooting arrows, this kind of demanding skill, which marks them out as kind of an elite warrior. And it's not just boys who are being raised to do this. Girls are as well. To follow this path of the warrior, to ride spirited horses and to love great arrows and strong bows. Because if the men are riding off to war, then the women have to be able to fight and hold their strongholds. This is the thinking. And so the culture of these eastern provinces is really strikingly different to that of the great imperial court. And to serve as a
完全正确。在那里，几个世纪以来，整个阶层的男人们都有一个习俗。他们可能是低级贵族，也可能是渴望向上流动的农民，从小就在马背上长大，练习射箭——这种高要求的技能使他们成为精英战士。不仅男孩被培养做这些，女孩也一样。她们追随武士之路，骑着烈马，喜爱强弓硬箭。因为如果男人们骑马去打仗，女人们就必须能够战斗并守住据点。这就是当时的思维方式。因此，这些东部省份的文化与伟大的皇室宫廷确实截然不同。要担任那里的……
governor there, as the Taira lords often do, you need to have retainers, samurai in Japanese, steeped in the East's martial values, these people who've been raised in the saddle. And the question is, what do nobleman like the Tira have to offer the samurai, to offer these hardened warriors? presumably patronage and various kinds of reward, I guess. So spoils of war. Land, of course. Land in the pre-industrial world is always the key to wealth and power. But maybe help in obtaining a post from the government.
总督，正如平氏领主经常做的那样，你需要有家臣，即日语中的“侍”（Samurai），他们沉浸在东方的尚武价值观中，也就是那些在马背上长大的人。问题是，像平氏这样的贵族能给武士、给这些久经沙场的战士提供什么呢？大概是庇护和各种奖励吧。比如战利品。当然还有土地。在前工业化世界，土地永远是财富和权力的关键。但也可能是帮助他们从政府获得职位。
If you're not kind of habituated to the ways of the court, the Tyra Lord may be able to pull strings for you. And if he can't do that, then he can kind of give you maybe a position of authority on his own lands, as a kind of official or whatever. And the degree to which you get these prizes, these rewards, depends on how well you have done. And there are very kind of finely graded appraisals that govern the performance of a samurai. And the classic example of this is what in Japanese is called bantori, which is the taking and counting of heads. and this is done as a way of assessing your performance in combat. So there's a very unsettling detail about Bantori in Jonathan Clement's history of the samurai.
如果你不习惯宫廷的行事方式，平氏领主或许能为你疏通关系。如果他做不到，他也可以在自己的领地上给你安排一个职位，比如担任某种官员之类的。而你获得这些奖赏的程度，取决于你的表现。有一套非常细致的评估标准来衡量武士的表现。最典型的例子就是日语中所说的“首取”（Bantori），即斩首并计数，这是评估战斗表现的一种方式。关于“首取”，乔纳森·克莱门茨的《武士史》中有一个非常令人不安的细节。
He writes, The verb for beheading in this context is not the stark slashing Kiru of a ritual execution, but the unpleasant, gritty Kubinaiji Kuru literally head twisting off and cutting. So there's a sense that when you're taking a head, it's not a bit of, a kind of neat slice. You're pinning your, you know, your enemy down and butchering him, you know, hacking his head off in a kind of really brutal, savage manner. And any heads that are not hacked off in the heat of battle, they will be collected once the fighting is over. And they'll be brought to a kind of central point piled up, identified, and tagged with labels. And the point of
他写道：在这种语境下，斩首的动词不是仪式性处决中那种干脆利落的“切”（Kiru），而是令人不快、粗糙的“首捻切”（Kubinaiji Kuru），字面意思是“扭头并切断”。所以，这说明当你取首级时，并不是那种利落的切割。你是在压制你的敌人，然后屠杀他，以一种非常残忍、野蛮的方式砍下他的头。任何在战斗激烈时没来得及砍下的头颅，都会在战斗结束后被收集起来。它们会被带到一个中心点，堆积起来，进行辨认并贴上标签。而这些标签的意义在于……
these labels is that the higher the rank of the beheaded warrior, the higher the reward. And And so there is a lot of beheading in Japanese art. And anyone who goes to the fantastic show on the Samurai at the British Museum that's on at the moment, there are a lot of illustrations of severed bodies. In the first episode, you were talking about how samurai culture was sort of perverted, as it were, and used as an inspiration for militaristic nationalism in the 1930s. There were loads of stories about beheading competitions by the Japanese soldiers in China when they took places like Nanjing. and, you know, people would be fated for beheading dozens, hundreds of Chinese victims, you know, in an afternoon or something. Horrific to us.
被斩首的武士等级越高，赏金就越高。因此，日本艺术中有很多斩首的画面。任何去参观大英博物馆目前正在举办的精彩武士展的人，都会看到许多断肢的插图。在第一集中，你谈到了武士文化是如何在20世纪30年代被扭曲，并被用作军国主义民族主义的灵感的。当时有很多关于日本士兵在中国（如南京）进行斩首比赛的故事，你知道，人们会因为在一个下午斩杀了几十、几百名中国受害者而受到赞扬。对我们来说，这太可怕了。
Do you think that's deliberate? That's a deliberate echo of what, of the sort of stories that are told about a samurai. Yeah, because there's a lot of beheading in the tale of the haiki. And, you know, every Japanese warrior would be familiar with that and with these stories. Absolutely. And for all that we talk about, the sort of chivalry, of the samurai and all this kind of thing, which, as you said in the first episode, again, maybe a slight 19th century invention. There is a sort of real darkness and brutality to
你认为这是故意的吗？这是对武士故事的一种刻意呼应吗？是的，因为《平家物语》中有很多斩首的情节。而且，你知道，每个日本武士都会熟悉这些故事。绝对是这样。尽管我们谈论武士的骑士精神等等，正如你在第一集中所说，这可能是一个19世纪的发明。这个故事中确实存在一种真正的黑暗和残暴，不是吗？我的意思是，当时有很多关于武士暴行的故事。人们在向朝廷投诉，不是吗？武士们做得太过分了，他们造成了绝对的痛苦和破坏。嗯，关于武士最著名的现代电影《七武士》，讲述的是农民雇佣武士来抵御强盗的袭击。但实际上，在这个时期，武士和强盗之间的界限非常模糊。所以正如你所说，当时总是有人向朝廷请愿，恳求正义。这里有一个988年的典型例子：为了自己的荣誉和名声，这些武士肆意挖出人们的眼睛。来到人们的……
this story, isn't there? I mean, there are stories from the time of samurai atrocities, as it were. People are complaining to the cause, aren't they? The samurai are going too far, that they're causing absolute suffering and devastation. Well, so the most famous modern film about the samurai, the seven samurai, revolves around samurai who are hired by peasants to see off the attack of bandits. But actually, certainly in this period, the border between samurai and bandit is very, very vague, very fluid. And so as you say, petitions are always being sent to the court in this period pleading for justice. So here's a typical example from 988. For the sake of their own honor and reputations, these samurai willfully pluck out people's eyes. Arriving at people's
家中，他们不下马，而是直接闯入。骑马的武士撕毁挂在屋外的木制遮阳帘，抢走税收物资。有趣的是，那份请愿书暗示，武士追求的不仅仅是战利品，他们还渴望荣誉。这是武士领主除了物质奖励外，还能提供给武士的东西——一个磨练名声、为自己赢得荣耀的机会，这些荣耀随后会代代相传给后代。因此，如果武士面临在丢脸和对无辜农民造成附带伤害之间做选择，那么普通武士总是会选择后者。
homes, they do not dismount from their horses, but enter. Samurai on horseback tear down the wooden shade screens that hang outside homes and carry off tax goods. And what's interesting about that, that petition is that it's suggesting it's not just loot that the samurai after, they are also hungry for honour. And this is something that a samurai lord has to offer as well as material reward, has to offer a samurai a chance to kind of burnish his reputation, to win glory for himself, which will then be passed down through the generations to his descendants. So if there is a choice between losing face for a samurai or kind of inflicting, you know, collateral damage on hapless peasants or whatever, then the average samurai is always going to opt for the former.
他总是会选择施加残暴和暴力。有一个非常可怕的故事说明了这一点，讲的是平贞盛，他是我们上一集提到的平将门（那个长着飞头的第一个武士）的堂兄弟兼死敌。贞盛在针对将门的战役中让将门陷入毁灭，并最终解决了他。但在晚年，贞盛因为在针对将门的战役中大腿中了一箭而感到羞辱。随着年龄增长，伤口开始恶化。
He's always going to inflict savagery and violence. And there's a really horrible story that illustrates this told of Saddamori, who was the cousin and bitter enemy of Tyroneau Massacado, who we talked about in our previous episode, the guy with the flying head, the first samurai. And Saddamori had brought Massacardo, who was his cousin down in ruin, finished him off. But in his old age, Sadamori, he feels humiliated by the fact that in that campaign against Massacardo, he had been hit by an arrow in the thigh. And as he gets older, the wound starts to wake.
他开始跛行。对于一个武士领主来说，跛行被视为一种耻辱和尴尬。于是，贞盛派人去京都请了一位医生。这位医生说：“哦，如果你的腿上有严重的箭伤并且引起疼痛，那么显然你需要一种用男胎肾脏制成的药。”于是贞盛说：“好吧。”他召来儿子说：“你妻子怀孕了，我要你剖开她的肚子，取出胎儿。”儿子对此感到脸色苍白，说：“您确定吗？”医生随后介入并……
And he gets a limp. And for a samurai lord to have a limp is seen as a cause of shame and embarrassment. And so Sadamori sends to Kyoto for. for a physician who comes out to him. And this physician says, oh, well, if you've got a bad arrow wound in your leg and it's causing you pain, then obviously you need a medicine made from the kidney of a male fetus. And so Sadamori goes, okay. And so he summons his son and says, your wife is pregnant. I want you to slice open her stomach and remove the fetus. And the son kind of blanches this and says, oh, are you really sure? And the physician then steps in and
说：“不，你不能那样做。血亲不能入药。”贞盛对此感到恼火。他派一名侍从去厨房。在那里，他们发现一名厨房女佣怀孕了。引用该来源的话：当他们剖开厨房女佣的肚子查看时，发现是一个女胎。于是他们把它扔掉了。然而，在别处又找到了另一个。总督（即贞盛）活了下来。所以药起作用了。正如引用这个故事的卡尔·弗莱所说：这个故事中对人类生命表现出的随意漠视令人震惊。我的意思是，对我们来说显然是这样。但问题是，贞盛完全不觉得他做错了什么。我的意思是，这被认为是理所当然的。所以再次引用弗莱的话：
says, no, you can't do that. A blood relative cannot become medicine. And so Saddamori is annoyed about this. He sends a chamberlain down into the kitchens. And there they find out that a kitchen maid is pregnant. To quote the source for this, when they opened up the kitchen maid's belly and looked, it was a female fetus. And so they threw it away. However, another was found elsewhere. The governor, which is Sadamori, survived. So the medicine worked. And as Carl Friday, who kind of quotes this story. The casual disregard displayed for human life in this tale is striking. I mean, and to us, it obviously is. But the thing is that Sadamore absolutely didn't feel that he'd done anything wrong. I mean, this is completely taken for granted. So again, to quote Friday,
无论是在战场上还是战场外，中世纪早期的日本武士似乎对他人生命几乎毫无关怀。我认为这绝对是武士文化最初的理想与中世纪基督教世界的骑士文化无法对应的一个非常明显的方面。没错。很有趣。你不会看到一个骑士那样做。骑士精神的全部意义在于尊重女性。
on or off the battlefield, early medieval Japanese warriors appear to have held little concern for the lives of others. And I think this is absolutely one of the really obvious ways in which the ideals of samurai culture as originally constituted, you know, they did not map onto the chivalric culture of medieval Christendom. Right. Interesting. You wouldn't have had a knight behaving like that. The whole point of chivalry is to show respect to women.
我认为，即使剖开女性肚子取出婴儿被视为犯罪，又能怎样呢？因为贞盛是总督，他受皇室当局委托负责其辖区的治安，所以实际上他就是法律。唯一可能改变这种情况、让总督因犯罪被传讯的方法，就是敌对的军阀能说服京都他是一个叛军。当然，这正是贞盛对将门所做的事情。
And I think that even if slicing open women to remove their babies had been viewed as a crime, you know, still, I mean, what could anyone on the scene have done? Because Saddamori is the governor. and so he's been entrusted by the imperial authorities with the policing of his province, and so in effect, he is the law. And the only way that this might change, and a governor might find himself kind of arraigned for a crime, is if a rival warlord could persuade Kyoto that he was a rebel. And that, of course, is what Saddamori had done with Massacardo,
因为平氏的敌对领主们完全有能力互相攻击。贞盛最终获胜了，因为他虽然不如将门那样善战，但他与朝廷的关系更好。因此，他能够疏通那些关系。他最终被任命为天皇的代理人。最终，这注定了将门的命运。但我们在上一集中提到，实际上有两个不同的氏族，不是吗？两个源自皇室的王朝。一个是平氏，但还有一个是源氏（Minamoto）。源氏也扎根于本州岛的东北部，不是吗？
because, you know, the rival lords of the Tyra are perfectly capable of turning on one another. And Sadamori ultimately had won, because he's not. not as good a warrior as Massacardo, but he had better contacts in the court. And so he'd been able to pull those strings. He ends up being appointed the emperor's agent. And ultimately, this is what dooms Massacardo. But we mentioned in the previous episode that there were actually two different clans, aren't there? Two different dynasties that are descended from the imperial family. So there's the, the Tyra, but there is also the Minamoto. And the Minamoto are all also embedded in the northeast of Honshu, aren't they?
从长远来看，甚至更深。这是日本真正的无法无天的荒地。本州岛上最粗犷、最尚武、武士最泛滥的地区。因此，我想说到了11世纪末，源氏开始在实力上超过平氏。所以现在，当这些东北省份发生暴力事件时，是源氏在把自己表现为法律和秩序的代理人，并将平氏描绘成不法之徒。例如，在1027年，一位源氏军阀通过写信给皇宫推翻了一位平氏对手，他说：“这个家伙，这个平氏，是一只狼贪鼠窃的家伙，他颠倒了朝廷的结构，为自己搜刮税收和物资，无视皇室命令。”这是更广泛趋势的一个征兆，到了12世纪，源氏已经明确确立了自己作为这些东部省份的主导力量，这些省份位于……
Even more so, actually, in the long run. And this is the real kind of, the lawless kind of badlands of Japan. The roughest, the most militaristic, the most samurai infested reaches of Honshu, the main island in Japan. And as a result of this, I would say by the end of the 11th century, the Minamoto are starting to outmustle the Taira. And so now when there is violence in these northeastern provinces, it's the Minamoto who are getting to present themselves as the agents of law and order and to cast the Tyra as the outlaws. So in 1027, for instance, there's a Minamoto warlord who topples a Tyra rival by writing to the imperial palace and saying this guy, this Tyra, he is a rat of wolf-like greed who had turned the structure of the court upside down, collecting taxes and tax goods for himself and ignoring imperial orders. And this is symptomatic of a broader trend so that by the 12th century, the Minamoto have clearly established themselves as the dominant power in these eastern provinces that lie to the
将它们与京都隔开的山脉以东。有两个特定的地区是他们的据点。一个是高地地区，叫信浓，位于本州岛中部的内陆。如果你看日本地图，本州岛，信浓基本上就在正中间。它几乎是坚不可摧的，因为地形非常多山，但它被一条叫木曾川的河流切割，这形成了一个切割山脉的峡谷，既易守难攻，又在战略上至关重要，因为它提供了一条通道，让军队……
east of the mountains that separate them from Kyoto. And there are two particular regions that are their strongholds. So one of them is an upland region, called Shinano, absolutely in the interior of central Honshu. So if you look at the map of Japan, the main island of Honshu, Shinano is kind of basically bang in the middle. And it's almost impregnable because the terrain is so mountainous, except that it is scored by this river called Kiso, and this provides a kind of valley that scores the mountains, and it's easily defensible, but it's also strategically vital because it provides a way that army
从信浓的山区高地顺着这个山谷流出，进入平原。这就是木曾谷。所以现在如果你想看那种老式的日本村庄，那种非常风景如画、非常适合旅游的地方，就像日本的科茨沃尔德，这就是你要去的地方。必须说，在11世纪，它一点也不适合旅游，但它在这个故事中将占据重要地位。它确实非常多山。如果你想建立一个与京都抗衡的权力基地，你真正需要的是平原，在那里你可以种植水稻、食物和各种东西。源氏在本州最大的平原建立了他们的权力基地，这就是关东平原。所以字面意思是“关之东”，即……
from the mountainous heights of Shinano can kind of go down this valley and spill out into the plain. This is the Kiso Valley. So this is now where you go if you want to see kind of old-fashioned Japanese villages and kind of, you know, it's very picturesque and very touristy, kind of the cotswolds of Japan. It wasn't remotely touristy back in the 11th century. It has to be said, and it will be featuring strongly in this story. But it is very mountainous. And what you really want, if you're going to set up a rival power base to Kyoto is a plane, you know, where you can grow rice and food and all kinds of things. And the Minamoto establish their power base in the largest plane in Honshu, and this is the plane of Kanto. So literally east of the barrier, so the barrier
将它与京都隔开的山脉。它比关西（京都所在的关之西的平原）更广阔，潜力也大得多。在12世纪，它与关西相比仍然非常不发达，但充满了潜力。在这一时期，它见证了一个叫“江户”的小定居点的建立，它在适当的时候将成为东京，即东方的首都，也就是今天的日本首都。所以，到了12世纪，本州岛的东半部基本上处于源氏的控制之下。他们拥有信浓这个巨大的山区，以及关东平原。这是否意味着他们现在是整个日本的主导力量？
is the mountain separating it from Kyoto. It's broader. It's potentially much richer than Kanzai, the plain west of the barrier on which Kyoto stands. And it is in the 12th century still very undeveloped compared to Kanzai, but it is full of potential. And in this period, it sees the establishment of a small settlement called Edo, which in due course will become Tokyo, the eastern capital, so the capital of Japan today. So, the eastern half of Honshu by the 12th century is essentially under the thumb of the Minamoto. They have Shinano, this great kind of mountainous region, and they have the plain of Kanto. Does this mean, therefore, that they are now the dominant power across the whole of Japan?
多米尼克，这并不意味着，因为尽管平氏基本上放弃了本州岛的东半部给源氏，但他们还有别的事情要做。因为与源氏相比，他们更多地保留了传统日本贵族的视角，认为本州岛的东部地区是落后的、野蛮的，根本不是绅士该去的地方。而岛屿的西半部，特别是关西，因为那里有京都，那个大平原，那才是真正重要的地方。这就是为什么在11和12世纪，他们选择从本州岛的东部撤出，开始将精力集中在那些一直是日本帝国传统核心地带的地方。
Dominic, it does not mean that, because although the Taira have essentially abandoned the eastern half of Honshu to the Minamoto, they do have other fish to fry. Because much more than the Minamoto, they have kind of retained the perspective of the traditional Japanese aristocracy, the sense that the eastern reaches of Honshu are backward, are savage, not the place for a gentleman to be seen at all. And it's the western half of the island. And Kansai, particularly, because that's where Kyoto is, the Great Plain, it's Kansai that really matters. And this is why over the course of the 11th and 12th century, countries, they had opted to withdraw from the eastern reaches of Honshu and start to focus their energies on what have always been the kind of traditional heartlands of the Japanese Empire.
因此，到1150年，他们已经确立了自己作为日本西部明确的主导力量，而且不仅是在陆地上，因为他们还控制着所谓的“濑户内海”。对于那些不熟悉日本地理的人来说，西南部的岛屿，日本群岛的最底端，就像一个岛屿化的德文郡和康沃尔郡。然后还有另一个岛叫四国，就像一个巨大的怀特岛，沿着南部海岸一直延伸。是的，比怀特岛大得多。大得多。所以这两个紧邻本州岛的岛屿，即九州和四国，创造了所谓的濑户内海。濑户内海的意义在于，它保护航运免受否则会席卷而来并构成持续危险的猛烈风暴。因此，这些是日本水域中迄今为止最安全的航道。平氏基本上确立了对这些水域的控制。在1140年代和1150年代，一位才华横溢、雄心勃勃的年轻总督清盛为他们巩固了这些航道。
And so by 1150, they have established themselves as clearly the dominant power in Western Japan and tellingly not just by land, because they also control what is called the inland sea. and for those not familiar with the geography of Japan, the southwestern island, the bottom tip of the Japanese archipelago, it's like a kind of Devon and Cornwall that is an island. And then there's another island called Shikoku, and that is like a massive Isle of White, which runs all the way along the kind of the southern coast. Yeah, much bigger than the Isle of White. Much, much bigger than the Isle of White. And so these two islands that abut Honshu, the main island, so Kushu and Shikuku, they kind of create this, what's called the inland sea. And the point of the inland sea is that it protects shipping from the violent storms that otherwise would kind of sweep down and be a constant danger. And so these are by far the securest shipping lanes anywhere, you know, the waters off Japan. And the Tyra essentially established their control over these waters. and they are particularly secured for them in the 1140s and 1150s by a brilliantly able and ambitious young governor who goes by the name of Kiomori.
清盛在本州南部海岸和四国北部海岸建立了新的港口。他疏浚航道。他使航运路线更加安全。一旦这些航运路线得到保障，它们反过来使平氏能够控制贸易，从而为他们创造了巨大的财富，并使他们能够比陆路更容易地调动军队，因为正如我们所说，日本非常多山。所以通过船只运送军队比走陆路快得多。当然，这也提供了通往京都的便捷通道，因为京都所在的平原……
And Kiomori founds new ports, both along the southern coast of Honshu and the northern coast of Shikoku. He dredges channels. He makes the shipping lanes more secure. and these shipping lanes in turn, once they've been secured, enable the Tyra to control trade, which thereby generates enormous wealth for them, to move troops much more easily than they can by land, because as we said, Japan is very, very mountainous. So taking troops by ships, you know, it's much faster than going by road. And of course, it provides ready access to Kyoto, because the plane on which Kyoto stands
面向濑户内海。如果你控制了京都，那么你当然就控制了皇宫。如果你控制了皇宫，那么你当然就控制了天皇。到目前为止，平氏和源氏之间的权力变得如此巨大，以至于他们中的一些人，无论是平氏还是源氏，都开始考虑一种诱人的可能性，多米尼克，你一直说，这在长期来看总是会发生的。这种可能性是：如果他们直接夺取对天皇的控制权，并把他当作傀儡会怎样？嗯，如果有一群人拿着武器、剑，而另一群人拿着书法工具，我总是押注于那些拿剑的人。
is open to the inland sea. And if you control Kyoto, then of course you control the palace. And if you control the palace, then you control the emperor. And by now, the power of the Tyra and the Minamoto between them is becoming so preponderant that some of them, both Tyra and Minamoto, are starting to contemplate a tantalizing possibility, which, Dominic, you've been saying, you know, it was always something that was going to kick in in the long run. And this possibility is, what if they seize direct control of the emperor and use him as a puppet? Well, if there's a load of people armed with weapons, swords, and there's a lot of people armed with calligraphy kits, my money is always on them, people with the swords.
我发现我是对的，这并不奇怪。你是对的。因为正如我们在上一集中所说，京都的贵族们一直表现得好像历史已经终结，好像你不需要武装自己，好像过着诗歌、求爱和美感的生活永远不会结束。但正如常有的那样，历史永远不会终结。如果你不武装自己，你总是会面临问题。对于京都的朝廷来说，危机点出现在一个非常具体的日子。
I'm not surprised to discover that I was right. You are right. Because all this time, as we said in the previous episode, the nobility in Kyoto have been behaving as though history has come to an end, as though you don't need to arm yourself. as though, you know, living a life of poetry and courtship and beauty and so on, as though that's never going to come to an end. But as always happens, you know, history never comes to an end. And if you don't harm yourself, you are always going to face problems. And for the court in Kyoto, the crisis point comes on a very specific day.
这就是1156年7月20日。这一天，那位在京都担任皇位背后权力者超过30年的人去世了。他的官方头衔是“上皇”，一个叫鸟羽的人。他是上皇，因为他曾是天皇。他年少时即位，20岁时退位并进入寺院。他从寺院里作为皇室无可争议的族长进行统治。所以年轻的天皇继承了他，但上皇鸟羽本质上仍然是掌握权力缰绳的人。这听起来可能……
And this is the 20th of July 1156. And it comes with the death of the man who for more than 30,000, years had served as the power behind the imperial throne in Kyoto. And this was, his official title is his cloistered eminence, a man called Tobar. And he's a cloistered eminence because he had been emperor. He'd become emperor as a boy. He had then abdicated at the age of 20 and gone to a monastery. And he had presided from this monastery as the kind of the undisputed patriarch of the imperial family. So young emperors have succeeded him, but his cloistered eminence, Tober, remains essentially the guy who has the reins of power in his hands. And this may sound
对听众来说很疯狂。我的意思是，如果你是天皇，为什么要退休成为和尚之类的？但这是到12世纪中叶，皇位继承运作了三个世纪的方式。整个做法是日本三大政治王朝中第三个王朝的结晶，我们在关于紫式部的系列节目中提到过，但在那之前我们没提过。这个王朝叫藤原氏。藤原氏没有像平氏和源氏那样去省份建立自己的权力基地。藤原氏留在了京都，他们的行动领域就是宫廷本身。引用伊万·莫里斯的话……
mad to listeners. I mean, why, if you're the emperor, are you kind of retiring and becoming a monk and all this kind of thing? But it's the way that the imperial succession had been operating for basically three centuries by this point, by the mid-12th century. And the whole practice had been the brainchild of the third of the three great political dynasties in Japan, which we haven't mentioned until now, although we did in our series on Lady Murasaki. And this is a dynasty called the Fujiwara. And the Fujiwara had not done what the Tyra and the Minamoto had done, go out into the provinces and build a power base for themselves there. The Fujiwara had remained in Kyoto, and their field of operations had been the court itself. And to quote Ivan Morris,
他在关于紫式部和源氏物语世界（即“光之君”的世界）的精彩著作中写道：藤原氏强加给天皇一种几乎注定要让他处于家族控制之下的生命周期，也就是藤原氏的控制之下。他作为一名稚嫩的青年即位，并立即与一名藤原氏女孩结婚。他们的儿子将被任命为皇太子，当他的父亲通常在30岁左右被迫退位时，他将继位，循环再次开始。显然，只要没有暴力的武士王朝在你脖子上喘气，这对藤原氏来说是有效的。但问题是，到了12世纪中叶，武士不再局限于遥远的省份。他们越过了山脉，
his brilliant book on the world of Lady Murasaki and Genji, the world of the shining prince. The Fujiwara had imposed on the emperor a type of life cycle that was almost bound to keep him under the family's thumb, so the Fujiwara's thumb. He came to the throne as a callow youth and was promptly married to a Fujiwara girl. Their son would be appointed crown prince, and when his father was obliged to abdicate usually at the age of about 30, he would succeed him and the cycle would start again. And obviously, this works for the Fujiwara as long as you don't have violent warrior dynasties breathing down your neck. But the problem is that by the middle of the 12th century, the samurai are no longer confined to distant provinces. They've crossed the mountains,
进入了京都，他们在首都的街道上游荡。结果，藤原氏统治的时代开始走向衰落。因为从现在开始，将是平氏和源氏共同决定皇位继承。随着上皇鸟羽的去世，平氏和源氏的敌对派系支持皇位的竞争候选人。所以此时，并不是平氏支持一个人，源氏支持一个人。
they've entered Kyoto, they are roaming the streets of the capital. And as a result, the age of Fujiwara dominance is starting to go into eclipse. Because, from now on it is going to be the Tyra and the Minamoto, who between them decide the imperial succession. And with the death of his cloistered eminence, Tober rival factions of Tyra and Minamoto backing rival candidates for the throne. So at this point, it's not like the Tyra are backing one guy and the Minamoto are backing one guy.
平氏和源氏混在一起，但这些不同的派系支持皇位的竞争候选人。这预示着危险。问一个愚蠢的问题：如果鸟羽去世了，他不是天皇，为什么会有继承危机？因为鸟羽作为家族族长，在决定谁将继承他方面发挥着关键作用。所以他不是官方的天皇，但他确实拥有真正的权力，因为他的威望、年龄、智慧和老练意味着他的意见受到尊重，甚至藤原氏也必须尊重它。但现在他走了，没有……
Tyra and Minamoto are kind of mixing up, but these different factions are backing rival candidates for the throne. And this spells danger. ask a dim-witted question. Why if Tober has died and he wasn't emperor, why is there a succession crisis? Because Tobar in his role as the patriarch of the family plays a crucial role in deciding who is going to succeed him. So he is not officially emperor, but he does have authentic power because his prestige, his age, his intelligence, his sophistication means that his opinions are respected and even the Fujiwara have to kind of respect it. But now that he is gone, there isn't
任何人来扮演那个角色。这就是为什么这些平氏和源氏的敌对派系能够介入并填补真空。情况演变成了暴力，战斗在一夜之间就结束了。其原因说明了京都的朝臣们变得多么与世隔绝和天真。其中一个平氏-源氏派系受到一位藤原氏权贵的左右，他是一个非常虔诚地信奉孔子教义的人。所以此时在皇都，中国文化仍受到极大的尊重。因为孔子说伏击别人是非常糟糕的行为，你应该按规则行事。你知道，不要破坏游戏规则。他说发动突然袭击是违法的。
anyone to play that role. And so this is why these rival factions of Tyro Minamoto are able to step in and fill the vacuum. And it turns to violence and the fighting is all over in a single night. And the reason for that tells you a lot about how cloistered and naive the courtiers in Kyoto have become. So one of these kind of Tyra Minamoto factions, they are swayed by a Fujiwara Grandi, who is a man very devoted to the teachings of Confucius. So still at this point in the Imperial Capital, Chinese culture is viewed with enormous respect. And so because Confucius says that it's very bad form to ambush people, you should play according to the rules. You know, don't rip up the rules of the game. He says it's against the law to launch a surprise attack.
实际上，武士们全都是关于突然袭击的。这是他的愚蠢。珍珠港事件并非凭空而来。这有着悠久的武士传统。另一个派系，他们根本不在乎孔子。所以他们说，当然我们要发动袭击。于是他们在半夜伏击了对手。他们烧毁了他们的总部，并赢得了决定性的胜利。胜利派系的两位领袖，一个是源氏，一个是平氏，然后，故事是这样说的……
Actually, the samurai are all about surprise attacks. This is idiocy from him. The bombing of Pearl Harbor didn't come from nowhere. This is a long samurai tradition. The other faction, they don't give a toss about Confucius. And so they say, well, of course we're going to launch an attack. So they ambush their opponents in the middle of the night. They burned down their headquarters, and they win a decisive victory. And the two leaders of the victorious faction, one is a Minamoto, one is a Tyra, they then, so the story goes,
他们用被俘对手的鲜血签署了盟约。这有点像第二次三头政治，安东尼、屋大维和雷必达，把手指浸在他们自己亲戚的鲜血中。所以这两位领袖之一，一个叫源义朝的人，据说公开斩首了他自己的父亲。天哪，拜托。我的意思是，这有点过分了。你必须做你必须做的事。而另一个……
they seal their pact with the blood of their captured opponents. So it's a bit like with the second triumvirate, Anthony and Octavian and Leopardus, kind of dipping their fingers in the blood of their own relatives. So one of these two leaders, a guy called Minamoto no Yoshitomo, he is said to have publicly beheaded his own father, Jesus, come on. I mean, that's a bit strong. You've got to do what you've got to do. And the other,
平清盛，也就是那个一直在濑户内海活动、建造所有那些港口、疏浚航道等等的人。他处死了他的叔叔。我认为这很公平。我的意思是，叔叔就是叔叔，但父亲是另一回事。这是京都三百年来的第一次公开处决。它们让所有人毫无疑问地意识到，一个新时代已经到来。因为这些被处决的权贵的头颅被插在长矛上，放在京都的市场上。所以每个人都能亲眼看到发生了什么。等等。日本距离上一次公开处决和这些杀戮之间的时间跨度……
Tyrono Kiyomori, so he is the guy who's been operating in the inland sea, building all those ports and dredging the shipping lanes and all that kind of thing. He puts his uncle to death. I think that's fair enough. I mean, an uncle is an uncle, but your father is a different matter. These are the first public executions in Kyoto for three and a half centuries. And they leave no one in any doubt that a new era has dawned. Because the head. heads of these executed grandees are put on spikes and put up in the Kyoto marketplace. So everyone can see for themselves what's going on. So hold on. There's a bigger gap in Japan between the last public executions and these killings
比我们明天在英国进行公开处决与之前的公开处决之间的时间跨度还要大。所以这一定是一个巨大的文化冲击。是的，巨大的文化冲击。以防万一，你知道，首都里的任何人还没意识到一个新时代已经到来，他们需要为文化冲击做好准备，更多的戏剧性事件即将发生。因为三年后的1159年，源义朝，也就是那个据说砍下了他父亲头颅的人，非常愤恨他的平氏盟友清盛在朝廷获得的奖赏比他多。他想，去他的，我要发动政变。他与一位非常不满……
than there would be if we had public executions tomorrow in Britain with the previous public executions. So it must have been a huge culture shock. Yeah, massive culture shock. And just in case, you know, anyone in the capital hadn't twigged that a new era had dawned and that they need to brace themselves for a culture shock, more drama is to follow. Because three years after this, in 1159, Minamoto no Yoshitomo, so he's the guy who supposedly had chopped off the head of his father, he's very resentful that Kiomori, his Taira ally, has received greater rewards at court than he has done. He thinks, screw this, I'm going to launch a coup. And he teams up with a very disgruntled
且酗酒严重的藤原氏大臣联手。我认为通常情况下，如果你在策划政变，与一个酒鬼联手不是个好主意。清盛已经离开京都去朝圣了。清盛是一位非常虔诚的佛教徒，他去朝圣了。在清盛缺席期间，藤原氏大臣和义朝抓住了13岁的天皇。他们处决了清盛在首都最显眼的盟友，并再次把他们的头颅插在长矛上，放在京都的市场上。天哪，这个系列里有太多的斩首了。是的。
and massively alcoholic Fujiwara minister. And I think generally, if you're plotting a coup, it's not a good idea to team up with an alcoholic. Kiyamori has left Kyoto on pilgrimage. Kiyomori is a very devout Buddhist, and he's gone off on pilgrimage. And while Kiyomori is absent, the Fujiwari minister and Yoshitomo seize the 13-year-old emperor. They execute Kiyomori's most prominent allies in the capital, and once again stick their heads on spikes and put them in the marketplace of Kyoto. God, there's a lot of beheading in the series. Yeah.
突然间就有了。义朝认为清盛会被此吓倒，他不会回到首都，他会撤退，然后他就会成为义朝的囊中之物。但清盛根本没有这样做。他是一个非常、非常冷静的人，非常精明，非常深谋远虑。他没有逃往省份（这实际上会破坏任何控制权力杠杆的企图），而是回到了首都。他非常、非常冷静地住进了自己的宅邸，本质上是挑战义朝尽其所能。一周后，皇宫里发生了火灾。非常，你知道，是巧合还是清盛放的火？
there suddenly is. And Yoshitomo assumes that Kiomori is going to be intimidated by this, that he won't come back to the capital, that he'll retreat, and then he'll be kind of easy meat for Yoshitomo. But Kiomori does not do this at all. He's a very, very cool customer, very calculating, very shrewd. And rather than fleeing into the provinces, you know, which effectively would kind of doom any attempt to control the levers of power, he returns to the capital. he very, very coolly takes up residence in his own mansion and essentially dares Yoshitomo to do his worst. And then a week later, a fire breaks out in the palace. Very, you know, is it coincidence or has Kiomori started it?
不清楚。但这使得被义朝俘虏并作为人质的年轻天皇能够逃脱。他打扮成女人，脸上涂着厚厚的妆，裹着和服，在火灾的混乱中设法溜过守卫，进入了一辆牛车。他们设法逃出了皇宫的范围，他设法去投奔清盛。与此同时，当这一切发生时，当火焰在京都上空升起时，3000名武士被看到正在接近首都。人们正凝视着试图辨别他们的旗帜是什么颜色，因为源氏的颜色是白色，平氏旗帜的颜色是红色，随着武士们越来越近，人们看到他们是红色的。他们是平氏武士。而源氏武士……
Unclear. But what this does is that it enables the young emperor who has essentially been taken prisoner by Yoshitomo and is being held as a hostage. He dresses up as a woman, so cakes his face in heavy makeup, swathes himself in a kimono, manages to slip his guards amid the chaos of the fire into an ox drawn cart. They managed to escape the limits of the palace, and he makes his way to join Kiomori. And simultaneously, as this is going on, as the flames are kind of reaching into the sky above Kyoto, 3,000 samurai are seen approaching the capital. and people are kind of gazing out to try and distinguish what color their banners are, because the color of the Minamoto are white and the color of the Tyra banners are red, and as the samurai come closer and closer, people see that they are red. They are Tyra samurai. And the Minamoto samurai,
措手不及，完全处于劣势，进行了顽强的抵抗，但被迫逃跑。发动这次政变的源氏首领义朝也逃跑了，他前往京都以东的山区，向一位老盟友寻求庇护，而这位盟友，知道局势已定，立即在义朝洗澡时谋杀了他，这就是他的结局。所以义朝，你知道，源氏下了一步险棋，但他们输了。相反，胜利属于平氏，因此，具体来说属于现在无可争议地站在他们首位的清盛。所以朝廷、京都，因此帝国的缰绳现在掌握在清盛手中。
taken by surprise, completely outnumbered, put up a good fight, but are forced to flee. and Yoshitomo, who had attempted this coup, the Minamoto chief, he flees as well, he heads into the mountainous fastnesses east of Kyoto, takes refuge with an old ally, and this ally, knowing the way that the dice have fallen promptly murders Yoshitomo while he's in his bath, and that is the end of him. So Yoshitomo, you know, the Minamoto had played boldly, but they had lost. And instead, victory has gone to the Tyra, and so, specifically to the guy who now indisputably stands at their head, Kiamori. And so the court, Kyoto, and therefore the reigns of the empire are now in Kiomori's hands.
措手不及，寡不敌众，虽然奋力抵抗，但最终被迫逃亡。试图发动政变的源氏首领义朝也逃走了，他逃往京都东部的深山，投靠了一位老盟友。这位盟友见大势已去，便趁义朝洗澡时将其杀害，义朝的一生就这样结束了。源氏虽然大胆博弈，但最终还是输了。胜利属于平氏，确切地说是属于现在无可争议的领袖——清盛。于是，朝廷、京都，乃至整个帝国的统治权，现在都掌握在清盛手中。
And the big question is, what will he do? Because he is now the first samurai lord to be the de facto, if not the de jure, master of Japan. And there are further questions that we will be answering after the break. How come Kiomori owed this success to a fox? And why would he end up commemorated by the Japanese as one of the three great villains of history? Craig, one of the three great villains of history up there with John Lennon and Virginia Woolf. So come back after the break and we'll be talking about this guy, Kiomori, and there'll be some fox chats. Not fox tossing, sadly, but Fox chats. Where are my gloves?
最大的问题是，他会怎么做？因为他现在是第一位实际上（如果不是法律上）统治日本的武士领主。还有更多的问题，我们将在休息后回答。清盛的成功为何要归功于一只狐狸？为什么他最终会被日本人视为历史上三大恶人之一？克雷格，历史上三大恶人之一，和约翰·列侬、弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫并列。休息一下，回来后我们将讨论清盛这个人，还会聊聊狐狸。遗憾的是，不是扔狐狸，而是聊狐狸。我的手套在哪儿？
Come on, heat. Any day now? Winter is hard, but your groceries don't have to be. This winter, stay warm. Tap the banner to order your groceries online at walla.ca. Enjoy in-store prices without leaving your home. You'll find the same regular prices online as in-store. Many promotions are available both in store and online, though some may vary.
来吧，热量。随时都可能到来？冬天很冷，但你的杂货不必如此。这个冬天，保持温暖。点击横幅在walla.ca在线订购杂货。足不出户即可享受店内价格。在线价格与店内常规价格相同。许多促销活动在店内和在线均可享受，尽管有些可能有所不同。
When Westcham first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was pretty. peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to Westjetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Welcome back to the rest is history. The year is 1159, and Kyoto is a city in shock. There is smoke drifting over the rooftops of the capital.
当西捷航空（WestJet）在1996年首次起飞时，氛围有点不同。人们认为牛仔配牛仔是时尚巅峰，轮滑鞋随处可见，三分之二的女性留着“瑞秋”发型。虽然这些东西留在了90年代，但有一件事没有变，那就是当你登上西捷航空时感受到的那种温暖。为96年以来的西捷航空干杯。和我们一起穿越时空，在westjet.com/30years与我们一起旅行。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1159年，京都正处于震惊之中。首都的屋顶上飘着烟雾。
The heads of some of the greatest men in Japan have been stuck onto spikes. And for the first time in Japan's history, a samurai bestrides the court like a colossus. And this is Taira no Kiyomori. Now, he has been descended from an emperor because the Taira are from the imperial family, albeit slightly obliquely. but to the people, I mean the literal pen pushers at the imperial court, the calligraphers and poets, he is a jumped up common vulgar parvenu. He's a soldier.
日本一些最伟大人物的头颅被插在长矛上。日本历史上第一次，一位武士像巨人一样跨越朝廷。这就是平清盛。他出身于天皇，因为平氏来自皇室，尽管血缘稍微有点远。但对人们，我是指那些在朝廷里只会写字的文官、书法家和诗人来说，他是一个暴发户，一个粗俗的平民。他是个军人。
Because he's a soldier. Right, exactly. I suppose they're not really pen pushes either. They're using brushes. Brushes. That's actually worse than a pen pusher. I think so. And the tale of the high key, who gives us this story, is very conscious of what has been lost with this.
因为他是个军人。没错，正是如此。我想他们也不完全是文官。他们用的是毛笔。毛笔。这其实比文官更糟糕。我也这么认为。而为我们讲述这个故事的《平家物语》，非常清楚随之失去的是什么。
It gives us a very wistful sense of, you know, it's kind of like someone in 1916 looking back at the Edwardian period. Ah, how lovely it was then on mornings beneath the blossoms on nights bright with a perfect moon to make music and poetry to sport at football, archery, to vie for the prettiest fan, for the most attractive painting, the most amusing bug or plant. I like the fact that both football and botany and bug collecting is part of it. what is lost with the coming of the samurai. And the role that Kiamori plays in the destruction of this idyll, which of course, as we've been saying, is one in which warriors never had any place at all. This is sufficient to see him ranked by Japanese tradition, as we said before the break,
它给我们一种非常惆怅的感觉，你知道，这就像1916年的人回顾爱德华时代一样。啊，那时在花下的清晨，在明月皎洁的夜晚，弹琴作诗，踢球、射箭，争夺最漂亮的扇子、最吸引人的画作、最有趣的虫子或植物，那是多么美好。我喜欢足球、植物学和收集昆虫都是其中的一部分。随着武士的到来，这一切都失去了。清盛在摧毁这种田园生活中的角色，正如我们一直所说的，这是一个武士根本没有立足之地的地方。这足以让他被日本传统列为，正如我们在休息前所说，
as one of the three great villains of history. And that is because he has been a traitor to the imperial throne. He has turned on the emperor. And this is the most shocking thing that anyone in Japan can do. And he's a domineering figure in the history of Japan. And posterity is appalled by him, but also, I think, impressed. He is a very impressive man. There's something perhaps of people's attitude to Cromwell about him, I think. Yeah, or Warwick the Kingmaker or somebody, I suppose. Why does he owe it all to a fox? That's the question that I think would be perplexing a lot of people. Because as a young man, he had gone hunting and he had shot a fox, and then to quote the source for this story, the fox changed into a beautiful woman and said
历史上三大恶人之一。这是因为他背叛了皇位。他背叛了天皇。这是日本任何人能做的最令人震惊的事情。他是日本历史上一个专横的人物。后人对他感到震惊，但我想，也对他印象深刻。他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。我想，人们对他的态度可能有点像对克伦威尔的态度。是的，或者像沃里克伯爵“造王者”之类的人。为什么他把这一切都归功于一只狐狸？我认为这个问题会让很多人感到困惑。因为他年轻时去打猎，射杀了一只狐狸，然后引用这个故事的来源，狐狸变成了一个美丽的女人，说
that if he would only spare her, then she would grant him all his desires. And so Kiamori let the fox go. And sure enough, the fox kept her word. And all Kiamori's wishes did come true, except that they were always shadowed by an ominous warning that the fox lady had also delivered, namely that when the moment of Kiamari's death approached, everything that he had achieved in his life would crumble away to dust. So he's given both opportunity, but told that ultimately it will all fade and go. And I think it's the measure of Kiamori's greatness and the way that he's commemorated as a very, very serious player in Japanese history that he clearly attracted stories like this. And I think also there is kind of something vulpine about him. He does have a quality of the
如果他能饶她一命，她就会满足他所有的愿望。于是清盛放走了狐狸。果然，狐狸信守了诺言。清盛所有的愿望都实现了，只是它们总是被狐狸女士留下的一个不祥的警告所笼罩，即当清盛临死之时，他一生所取得的一切都将化为尘埃。所以他既得到了机会，又被告知最终这一切都会消逝。我认为，清盛的伟大以及他作为日本历史上一个非常、非常重要的人物被纪念的方式，足以说明他显然吸引了这样的故事。而且我认为他身上确实有一种狐狸般的特质。他有一种
fox himself because he's very cunning. He's very artful. He's very scheming. But also, and it's quite a lot because we said it's a very devout Buddhist. He's very, very proficient. at strategically well-timed displays of salutary violence. He knows how to commit an atrocity in a way that will have a real impact. Yeah, because he has defeated the great Minamoto kind of warlord, his guy called Yoshitomo, and he executed his son, and then he had the second son's head put on a spike in Kyoto. So it's all about spectacular displays of violence that will intimidate his adversaries. Yeah, and the spike action in Kyoto is still very much going on.
狐狸本身的特质，因为他非常狡猾。他非常机敏。他非常善于算计。但同时，这也很重要，因为我们说过他是一个非常虔诚的佛教徒。他非常、非常擅长。在战略上适时地展示有益的暴力。他知道如何实施暴行，从而产生真正的影响。是的，因为他击败了伟大的源氏军阀，那个叫义朝的人，他处决了他的儿子，然后把第二个儿子的头颅插在京都的矛上。所以这一切都是为了通过壮观的暴力展示来恐吓他的对手。是的，京都的“插头”行动确实还在继续。
So he's clearly very brutal where he feels he has to be. At the same time, he is, you know, this is part of the complexity of his character. He is also capable of really striking displays of clemency at the same time. And the most striking of these is the mercy that he shows the younger sons of Yoshitomo, the surviving sons. So Yoshitomo's heir, you know, his eldest and his second eldest son have been killed. But his third son, so he's now, you know, the older surviving son, is a 13-year-old boy, and this is a boy called Yoritomo.
所以他显然在必要时非常残忍。与此同时，你知道，这是他性格复杂的一部分。他同时也能够表现出非常惊人的宽容。其中最引人注目的是他表现出的对义朝幼子，即幸存儿子的仁慈。所以义朝的继承人，你知道，他的长子和次子都被杀了。但他的第三个儿子，也就是现在幸存的长子，是一个13岁的男孩，这个男孩叫赖朝。
And Yoritomo is spared by Kiomori. And the question, therefore, must be why? I mean, why would you spare the son of your bitterest enemy? The reason for this, and it's an absolutely classic example of how complex Japanese dynastic policies can be, is that Yoritomo's mother, so the mother of the mother of the this 13-year-old boy, this Minamoto boy, is also Kiamori's stepmother. The two clans are actually linked. Yeah.
赖朝被清盛饶了一命。因此，问题必然是为什么？我的意思是，你为什么要饶了你最死敌的儿子？其原因，这是日本王朝政治复杂性的一个绝对经典例子，那就是赖朝的母亲，也就是这个13岁男孩，这个源氏男孩的母亲，也是清盛的继母。这两个氏族实际上是有联系的。是的。
Yeah. There is intermarriage. And so Kiyamori's stepmother, Yorotomo's mother, please for Yorotomo's life. And Kiyomori thinks, well, he's 13 years old. What damage can he do? Particularly if I banish him from Kyoto, so that he kind of grows up in provincial obscurity. And so he's sent into exile, first on a small island, and then to a mountain. peninsula called Isu, which is a kind of coastal backwater just west of Kanto. It's a kind of
是的。有联姻。所以清盛的继母，赖朝的母亲，为赖朝求情。清盛想，好吧，他才13岁。他能造成什么破坏？特别是如果我把他从京都流放，让他成长在偏远的乡下。于是他被流放，先是在一个小岛上，然后是一个叫伊豆的山区半岛，那是一个关东以西的沿海偏僻之地。这是一种
a peninsula sticking out into the sea. And anyone who's seen Shogun, this is the region where John Blackthorn's ship in the first episode washes up. And it is Kiomori's expectation that Yoritomo will rot there until he dies. Yorotomo has three younger brothers, so even younger than him, and these are also banished. And these are the sons. of Yoshitomo by a low-ranking but incredibly beautiful lady-in-waiting called Tokiwa. And Tokiwa, when Kiomore had seized control of Kyoto, had fled the capital, and it's a very, very famous scene in Japanese culture. She is shown fleeing through a snowstorm, holding her two elder boys by their hands,
伸入大海的半岛。任何看过《幕府将军》的人都知道，这是第一集中约翰·布莱克索恩的船被冲上岸的地区。清盛的期望是赖朝会在那里腐烂直到死去。赖朝有三个弟弟，比他还小，他们也被流放了。这些是义朝与一位地位低下但极其美丽的侍女常盘所生的儿子。当清盛夺取京都的控制权时，常盘逃离了首都，这是日本文化中一个非常、非常著名的场景。她被描绘成在暴风雪中逃跑，手里牵着两个大儿子，
and holding the youngest, who is a little baby called Yoshitsune, wrapped up in her robes. And the snow kind of sweeps down. And if you go to the British Museum show about the samurai, the scene is beautifully illustrated there. So Tokiwa snow blustering everywhere, little baby Yoshitsune, just a kind of small arc of blue Tokuas breast. But she can't make it through the snowstorm. She's captured.
怀里抱着最小的，一个叫义经的小婴儿，裹在她的长袍里。雪花飘落。如果你去大英博物馆看关于武士的展览，那个场景被描绘得很美。所以常盘在风雪中，小婴儿义经，只是常盘胸前的一抹蓝色。但她无法穿过暴风雪。她被抓住了。
She's brought to Kiyamori. And Kiyamori is so enraptured by her beauty and by her charm that he says that, you He will spare her son's lives if she will come to his bed and become his concubine. And so she agrees. And in due course, her three sons are sent off to be novices in a monastery outside Kyoto. And again, Kiamori is expecting that this is to neutralize them, that they will grow up to be monks. And effectively, they will not become samurai. So that's his expectation.
她被带到清盛面前。清盛被她的美貌和魅力所吸引，以至于他说，如果她愿意来到他的床上成为他的妾，他就会饶了她儿子的性命。于是她同意了。不久之后，她的三个儿子被送往京都外的一座寺院当见习僧人。同样，清盛期望这能中和他们，让他们长大后成为僧人。实际上，他们不会成为武士。这就是他的期望。
Whether that expectation is fulfilled or not, we will see in due course. Meanwhile, he thinks, I've dealt with the Minamoto, I've killed the dangerous ones, I've banished the kind of the children, they're all dealt with, don't need to worry about the Minamoto anymore. Now what's he going to do? Well, his aim essentially is to kind of maneuver himself into the very heart of the imperial state. So in the words of the tale of the Heke, tales of his deeds and ways surpass the imagination. Because to reiterate, no samurai lord has ever been in this position before. And over the years that follow this coup that has brought Kiyomori to power, he tramples down on every tradition that has been held precious by the
这种期望是否实现，我们以后会看到。与此同时，他想，我已经处理了源氏，杀了危险的那些，流放了孩子们，他们都处理好了，不需要再担心源氏了。现在他要做什么？好吧，他的目标本质上是把自己操纵到帝国国家的核心。所以用《平家物语》的话说，他的事迹和手段超出了想象。因为重申一下，以前从来没有武士领主处于这种位置。在导致清盛掌权的政变后的几年里，他践踏了帝国朝廷所珍视的每一项传统。
imperial court. So in 1160, he becomes the first samurai to be awarded an official court position. Seven years later, he becomes the chief minister. I mean, stupefying. Then in 1171, he does a Fujiwara and marries his daughter to the emperor. So this samurai, he's now the father-in-law of the emperor, stupefying. And then in 1178, he pulls off the big one because his daughter gives the emperor a son, which means that Kiomori now has every chance of seeing a Tyra, his own grandson, ascend the imperial throne of Japan. It is the most amazing moment of triumph. Incredible coup. And actually, it pays off, doesn't it?
所以1160年，他成为第一位被授予正式朝廷职位的武士。七年后，他成为首席大臣。我的意思是，令人震惊。然后在1171年，他效仿藤原氏，将女儿嫁给了天皇。所以这个武士，他现在是天皇的岳父，令人震惊。然后在1178年，他完成了大动作，因为他的女儿为天皇生了一个儿子，这意味着清盛现在有充分的机会看到一个平氏，他自己的孙子，登上日本皇位。这是最令人惊叹的胜利时刻。不可思议的政变。而且实际上，它得到了回报，不是吗？
Two years later, at the age of two, this boy, his grandson, is the emperor Antoku. Kiyomori has achieved the summit of all his desires. And yet, there must be loads of people in the court. The brush pushers and co. Who must regard this as the most tremendous assault on the traditions and the propriety of Japanese court? culture. Of course, they're all appalled. And Dominic, I'll tell you, the class of person who is most appalled is members of the imperial family, because, you know, they don't want the grandson of a Tyra samurai to sit on the throne that rightfully should be occupied by them. And a guy who's
两年后，两岁时，这个男孩，他的孙子，就是安德天皇。清盛实现了他所有的愿望。然而，朝廷里一定有很多人。那些“毛笔推手”之类的人。他们一定认为这是对日本朝廷传统和礼仪的最巨大冲击。当然，他们都感到震惊。多米尼克，我告诉你，最感到震惊的那类人是皇室成员，因为，你知道，他们不想让一个平氏武士的孙子坐在本应属于他们的宝座上。而一个特别被冒犯的人是一位叫以仁王的王子。他是前天皇的儿子，而且，你知道，那个“毛笔推手”。他的氛围非常
particularly offended is a prince called Machihito. And he's the son of a former emperor and, you know, the brush pusher. His vibe is very much. not that of a samurai. I'll quote the tale of the haiko. So beautiful did he write and such scholarly talent did he display that by rights he should have assumed the throne, because it's the ability to write and to be a scholar. This is what marks you out as a good emperor. But, you know, his ambitions now effectively are blocked by Kiamori and his dynastic manipulations. And so at the ripe old age of 29, Machaito increasingly feels he has nothing to lose. He cannot put up with this. He decides, well, I'm going to launch a coup. And for support,
不像武士。我引用《平家物语》。他写得如此优美，展现出如此的学术天赋，以至于按理说他应该继承皇位，因为写作能力和成为学者。这就是让你成为好天皇的标志。但是，你知道，他的野心现在实际上被清盛和他的王朝操纵所阻挡。所以在他29岁的大好年纪，以仁王越来越觉得他没什么可失去的了。他无法忍受这一点。他决定，好吧，我要发动政变。为了支持，
he turns to pretty much the only significant Minamoto who is still there in Kyoto. And this is a former samurai who's become a monk called Yorimasa. And Yorimasa has been tolerated by Kiyomori because in the attempted coup of 1160, he had sided with Kiyomori against the Minamoto. and Yoramasa has come to feel increasingly guilty about this. He is also very offended as a Buddhist monk by what he sees as Kiamori's contempt for Buddhist teachings. He feels that the Taira regime is kind of corrupting the teachings of the Buddha and that despite the fact that Kiomori is a very devout Buddhist, I mean, he may say he is, but he isn't in practice. Is that because there's too much heads on spikes for this guy's liking? All that kind of thing.
他转向了京都几乎唯一剩下的重要源氏。这是一位已经成为僧人的前武士，名叫赖政。赖政一直被清盛容忍，因为在1160年的政变企图中，他曾站在清盛一边反对源氏。而赖政对此感到越来越内疚。作为一名佛教僧人，他也对清盛对佛教教义的蔑视感到非常冒犯。他觉得平氏政权正在腐蚀佛陀的教义，尽管清盛是一个非常虔诚的佛教徒，我的意思是，他可能说他是，但他在实践中并非如此。这是因为对这个家伙的喜好来说，矛上的头颅太多了吗？所有那种事情。
But I think also Yorimasa associates Buddhist teaching with the proprieties of the court and feels that these are being trampled on and it's not what the Buddha would have wanted at all. So Yorimasa and Prince Moshihoto, they team up and they write this communique which they send out in secret to key players across Honshu. And this communique condemns Kiomori for his crimes against the teachings of the Buddha. And it specifically appeals to the Minamoto lords for military backing. So it goes out to, you know, all the key Minamoto lords out in the eastern provinces. And the obvious focus of their hopes is Yoritomo.
但我认为赖政也将佛教教义与朝廷的礼仪联系在一起，并觉得这些正在被践踏，这根本不是佛陀想要的。所以赖政和以仁王联手，他们写了这份公报，秘密发送给本州各地的关键人物。这份公报谴责清盛对佛陀教义的犯罪。它特别呼吁源氏领主提供军事支持。所以它发给了，你知道，东部省份所有关键的源氏领主。他们希望的明显焦点是赖朝。
And Yoritomo, he was the 13-year-old son of Yoshitomo, the guy who had been spared by Kiomori when he was 13, and by this point he is in his early 30s. He's still in Isou, this kind of backwater where Dutch ships get shipwrecked in the 16th century, all that kind of thing. He's lying low, but by now, you know, he's grown up and he's very, very keen to have his vengeance. And he is a hard, ruthless, brilliantly calculating man. Dominic, I think he's a man after your own heart. Oh, thanks, that's kind. Slight smack of the Captain Benton about him, I think.
而赖朝，他是义朝的13岁儿子，那个在13岁时被清盛饶了一命的家伙，到这个时候他已经30出头了。他还在伊豆，那种16世纪荷兰船只遇难的偏僻之地，所有那种事情。他保持低调，但现在，你知道，他长大了，非常、非常渴望复仇。他是一个坚硬、无情、极其精明的男人。多米尼克，我想他是一个和你志趣相投的人。哦，谢谢，那很客气。我想他身上有一点本顿船长的味道。
Does he have the surface cordiality of a Bentine? That's the question. Well, he does, because this is what has enabled him to avoid attracting the attention of Kiamori's spies. He's very good at suggesting a certain degree of amiability, but beneath that, there is a kind of hard, calculating core. And he has spent his time establishing very close links with the kind of the samurai and Isu, and also on the great plain of Kanto, which lies just to the east of Isu.
他有本顿那种表面的亲切感吗？这是个问题。嗯，他有，因为这使他能够避免引起清盛间谍的注意。他非常善于表现出一定程度的友善，但在那之下，有一种坚硬、精明的核心。他花时间与伊豆的武士，以及伊豆以东的关东大平原上的武士建立了非常密切的联系。
He has also married a female samurai, an honor Musha, as they're called. He was a woman trained in the practice of arms. And she is as impressive a woman, really, as Yoratomo is impressive, a man. And she is called Hojo Masako, and they are very well matched. And in the long run, they're going to prove themselves the Augustus and Livia of medieval Japan because both of them are going to demonstrate an absolute genius for the arts of politics and they are going to change the course of Japanese history. However, that's all in the future. For now, Yoritomo is very important to Yorimasa and the prince in their plotting. But the
他还娶了一位女武士，也就是所谓的“女武者”。她是一位受过武器训练的女性。她确实是一位和赖朝一样令人印象深刻的女性。她叫北条政子，他们非常般配。从长远来看，他们将证明自己是中世纪日本的奥古斯都和利维亚，因为他们两人都将展现出政治艺术的天才，他们将改变日本历史的进程。然而，那都是未来的事。目前，赖朝对赖政和王子的阴谋非常重要。但是
prince and Yorimasa do also have another focus of their hopes. And these are the Buddhist monks whose monasteries up on the mountains that surround Kyoto are also key players in this story. The communique that goes to the Minamoto also goes to these monasteries. And in part, they are asking the monasteries for spiritual backing, but they are also asking for military backing. And this is because the monasteries are teeming with warrior monks. The monasteries basically run their own security, their own police force. And actually, when Kiamori's spies bring him news of what, you know, these two conspirators are up to, he's much more worried about the monks than he is about, you know, what the Minamoto in their kind of distant exile
王子和赖政还有另一个希望的焦点。这就是佛教僧人，他们位于京都周围山上的寺院也是这个故事的关键参与者。发给源氏的公报也发给了这些寺院。在某种程度上，他们是在向寺院寻求精神支持，但他们也在寻求军事支持。这是因为寺院里挤满了僧兵。寺院基本上经营着自己的安全，自己的警察部队。实际上，当清盛的间谍带给他这两个阴谋者在做什么的消息时，他比担心，你知道，那些在遥远流放地的源氏
might be getting up to. He's relatively unfazed by it. He thinks it's not a big deal. He sends his police to go and arrest Prince Machaito. But Prince Machiito, but Prince Machiato, but Prince Machahito, he kind of pulls off what by now is becoming a very familiar stunt for members of the royal family who are threatened by arrest. He dresses himself up as a woman and slips out of the palace escorted by his guards. And there's a tremendous account of this in the tale of the heke. Fleeing north up Takakura Street, they came to a wide ditch. The prince leaped it lightly. What a fine way for a lady to hop over a ditch. A passerby stopped to exclaim, staring suspiciously. To be fair, I've never seen a woman hop over a ditch.
可能在做什么，要担心僧人得多。他对此相对镇定。他认为这没什么大不了的。他派警察去逮捕以仁王。但是以仁王，但是以仁王，但是以仁王，他完成了一种现在对受到逮捕威胁的皇室成员来说变得非常熟悉的特技。他把自己打扮成女人，在卫兵的护送下溜出了宫殿。在《平家物语》中有对此的精彩描述。沿着高仓街向北逃跑，他们来到了一条宽阔的沟渠。王子轻盈地跳了过去。女士跳过沟渠真是个好方法。路人停下来惊呼，怀疑地盯着看。公平地说，我从来没见过女人跳过沟渠。
Well, especially you wouldn't in Kyoto. I don't think that's the kind of thing. You wouldn't imagine Lady Murasaki hopping over a ditch. That would never happen. So anyway, so Prince Machaito, he escapes, gets out of the city, and he rides up to this monastery on a hill called Miedera. And there, a thousand monks rally to his cause. He's also joined by Yorimasa, who has bought a squad of perhaps 50 samurai.
嗯，特别是在京都你不会看到。我不认为那是那种事情。你不会想象紫式部跳过沟渠。那永远不会发生。所以无论如何，以仁王逃脱了，离开了城市，骑马去了山上的一座叫三井寺的寺院。在那里，一千名僧人聚集在他的旗帜下。赖政也加入了，他带来了一支大约50人的武士小队。
And the hope is that all the other monasteries, neighboring Miedera, will rally to Prince Michoito's cause as well. Unfortunately, however, they do not. And so Prince Michoito decides that he is going to head southwards to another great centre of Buddhist monasteries. And this is a very ancient Japanese city called Nara, famous today still for its monasteries and also for its deer. And this was the city that before Kyoto had served the emperor as his capital.
希望所有邻近三井寺的寺院也能聚集在以仁王的旗帜下。然而不幸的是，他们没有。所以以仁王决定他要向南前往另一个伟大的佛教寺院中心。这是一个非常古老的日本城市，叫奈良，今天仍然以其寺院和鹿而闻名。这是在京都之前作为天皇首都的城市。
And as I say, it's surrounded again by monasteries. And so therefore, again, teeming with a ready supply of warrior monks. And so this is the plan. Yorimasa, Prince Machaito. So Yorimasa is the monk. Prince Machuato is the guy ex-collegropha now in the doldrums. Yeah, a guy who dressed up as a woman and leapt over the canal, all of that. They've got samurai with them.
正如我所说，它再次被寺院包围。因此，再次挤满了现成的僧兵供应。所以这就是计划。赖政，以仁王。所以赖政是僧人。以仁王是那个前书法家，现在处于低谷。是的，一个打扮成女人跳过运河的家伙，所有这些。他们带着武士。
They've got warrior monks with them. They're heading down to Nara to try and recruit more warrior monks. and then they will return and attack Kyoto. This is the plan. Now, bear in mind, the prince has spent his entire life doing calligraphy and kind of making various perfume forms of incense. He's not a practice horseman. And so as they ride southwards towards Nara, he keeps falling off his horse. So he's not cutting an impressive dash. Nevertheless, by sunset, the prince and Yorimasa have reached a key crossing point. And this is a bridge over the deep and very churning rapids of a river called the Uji. They cross the bridge, and as they're doing this,
他们带着僧兵。他们正前往奈良，试图招募更多的僧兵。然后他们会回来攻击京都。这就是计划。现在，记住，王子一生都在做书法和制作各种香料。他不是一个熟练的骑手。所以当他们向南骑向奈良时，他不断从马上掉下来。所以他看起来并不令人印象深刻。尽管如此，日落时分，王子和赖政到达了一个关键的交叉点。这是一座横跨一条叫宇治的河流深处且湍急的急流的桥。他们过桥，当他们这样做时，
Yorimasa is informed by his scouts that a huge squad of Tyra cavalry are hot in pursuit. And so Yorimasa orders that the planks of the bridge over the Uji be ripped up. And the prince is sent to pass the night in a great Buddhist shrine called the Biodo Inn, which is still there in Uji to this day. it's stupefyingly impressive and beautiful, very rare survival from this period. So he goes off and camps out there. Meanwhile, Yorimasa and a crack squad of elite hand-picked men stand guard over the skeleton of the bridge and wait for the dawn.
赖政被他的侦察兵告知，一大队平氏骑兵正在紧追不舍。于是赖政下令拆除宇治桥上的木板。王子被派往一座叫平等院的伟大佛教神社过夜，这座神社至今仍矗立在宇治。它令人震惊地令人印象深刻和美丽，是这一时期非常罕见的幸存建筑。所以他去那里露营。与此同时，赖政和一支精挑细选的精英小队守卫着桥的骨架，等待黎明。
And their hope is that if they can only hold the bridge long enough, then monks from Nara will come to reinforce them and balance out the door. the odds, because as it stands, they are heavily outnumbered. So, you know, the night passes, the sun starts to rise, and with dawn, the defenders are able to see that the Tyra task force, many, many thousands strong, are descending on the river. And the vanguard of this Tyra force, they approached the bridge, they don't observe, I mean, this is what we're told, they must have been blind, but supposedly they don't see that the bridge is missing its planks. They gallop out onto the bridge and fall into the river and are swept away on the boiling torrents.
他们的希望是，如果他们能守住桥足够长的时间，那么来自奈良的僧人就会来增援他们，平衡力量。因为目前，他们的人数处于严重劣势。所以，你知道，夜晚过去了，太阳开始升起，随着黎明，守军能够看到平氏特遣部队，许多、许多数千人，正在向河流涌来。这支平氏部队的先锋，他们接近桥，他们没有观察，我的意思是，这是我们被告知的，他们一定是瞎了，但据称他们没有看到桥缺少木板。他们疾驰上桥，掉进河里，被沸腾的激流冲走。
Would you not notice? I mean, you would notice. Poetic license. So the Tyra commanders, you know, they are alerted to the fact that large chunk of the bridge is missing. They raise their hands and say, you know, they call a haught. They summon up their archers, and to quote the tale of the hakeh. Their finest archers lined up their bows, fitted out. arrow to string and let fly. Yorimasa's men, who are standing on the far side of the bank
你难道没注意到吗？我的意思是，你会注意到的。诗意的许可。所以平氏指挥官，你知道，他们被提醒桥的一大块不见了。他们举起手说，你知道，他们喊停。他们召集了弓箭手，引用《平家物语》。他们最优秀的弓箭手排好弓，搭上箭，射出。赖政的人，他们站在河对岸
opposite the Taira archers, they are ready to deal with this with all kinds of mad martial arts action, which is brilliantly described in the tale of the heke. So we're told that a particularly brave samurai called Tajima strides out alone onto the bridge and he knocks down the arrows with his naginata. So using it a bit like a cricket bat or a baseball bat, kind of knock them out of the sky. And a naginata is a kind of a sword crossed with a spear, has a curved blade. I guess the kind of the European equivalent would be a halberd. And he's kind of doing that playing arrow cricket with his naginata. And then as he's doing that, a monk, a warrior monk called Jomyo Meshu, he walks out onto another beam. Remember all the planks have been through.
面对平氏弓箭手，他们准备好用各种疯狂的武术动作来应对，这在《平家物语》中有精彩的描述。所以我们被告知，一个特别勇敢的武士叫多田，独自一人大步走上桥，他用他的薙刀击落了箭。所以用它有点像板球棒或棒球棒，把它们从空中击落。薙刀是一种剑和矛的结合体，有弯曲的刀刃。我想欧洲的对应物应该是长戟。他有点像在用他的薙刀玩“箭板球”。然后当他这样做时，一个僧兵，叫净妙明秀，他走上了另一根横梁。记住所有的木板都已经被
thrown into the river. And he has a tremendous innings. So he kills 25 Tyra with his arrows, we're told. He then mows down another five with his naginata. And then when his naginata snaps in two, he pulls out his sword and he kills eight more Tyra. Then his sword breaks. Now he only has his dagger, so he draws that. And at this point, another warrior monk called Ichre, comes running up behind him, leaning his hand on Jomio's helmet, we're told, with, pardon me, Icheray leaped over him and lit into the foe. In that battle, he died. Meanwhile, Jomeo has crawled back to the bank and on the grass at the Bayodo Inn gate, he took off his armour and counted 63 arrow hits. 63, wow, good armour. You know, he's still going strong. And all day,
扔进河里了。他有一场精彩的表演。所以我们被告知，他用箭杀死了25名平氏。然后他用薙刀又砍倒了五个。然后当他的薙刀断成两截时，他拔出剑，又杀了八名平氏。然后他的剑断了。现在他只有匕首了，所以他拔出匕首。就在这时，另一个僧兵叫一赖，跑在他身后，手扶着净妙的头盔，我们被告知，抱歉，一赖跳过他，冲向敌人。在那场战斗中，他死了。与此同时，净妙爬回岸边，在平等院门口的草地上，他脱下盔甲，数了数63个箭孔。63，哇，好盔甲。你知道，他还在坚持。整整一天，
the Tyra attempt to force the bridge and all day they are held at bay by this incredibly outnumbered band of defenders. And they're waiting, of course, for reinforcements to arrive from Nara. And the sun rises high in the sky and then it starts to set. And still, no reinforcements. The road from Nara stands empty. It's only a matter of time. And finally, towards evening, a squad of 300 Tyra horsemen decide that they have no choice but to ride into the boiling rapids, even though they're likely to be swept away, because they are threatened with disgrace if they cannot get across and attack their enemy, they ride into the rapids and a few of them are able to make the crossing. And this demonstrates to their
平氏试图强攻桥，整整一天他们都被这群人数处于严重劣势的守军挡在外面。他们当然在等待来自奈良的增援。太阳升到天空高处，然后开始落下。依然没有增援。通往奈良的道路空空如也。这只是时间问题。最后，傍晚时分，300名平氏骑兵决定他们别无选择，只能骑入沸腾的激流，尽管他们很可能会被冲走，因为如果他们不能过河攻击敌人，他们将面临耻辱，他们骑入激流，其中一些人能够完成过河。这向他们的
fellow samurai that it is possible to ford the Uji. And so the entire Tyra army, thousands and thousands of horsemen then follow across. And many, of course, are swept away on the currents, but actually the mass of men, you know, they're able to work out the shore's path and they make it across and they are now on the same side as the defenders. And because they hugely outnumber the defenders, they're able to envelop them and there's tremendous slaughter and all of Prince Michoito's men are pretty much wiped out and among them is the prince himself. There is, however, one man whom the Tyra do not kill, and this is the old warrior, the warrior monk, Minamoto no Yorimasa. And he, you know, he's effectively been the general, he's been the guy in
同伴武士证明了涉过宇治河是可能的。于是整个平氏军队，成千上万的骑兵随后跟进过河。当然，许多人被激流冲走，但实际上大批人，你知道，他们能够找到岸边的路径，他们成功过河，现在他们和守军在同一侧。因为他们的人数大大超过守军，他们能够包围他们，发生了巨大的屠杀，以仁王的所有人几乎被消灭，其中就包括王子本人。然而，有一个人平氏没有杀，这就是老战士，僧兵，源赖政。他，你知道，他实际上一直是将军，他是那个
command of this fighting force. He recognizes that it's all over. He recognizes the doom of his hopes. And so he summons his servant and says, you know, behead me, cut off my head. But the servant refuses. Take your own life first, my lord. Then I will oblige. And so Yorimasa turns to face the west where the sun is setting. And he intones the name of the Buddha ten times in a row. And then he composes poetry. And as he composes these lines, he speaks them. This forgotten tree never through the fleeting years burst into flower.
指挥这支战斗部队的人。他意识到一切都结束了。他意识到他希望的毁灭。于是他召集他的仆人说，你知道，斩首我，砍下我的头。但仆人拒绝了。主公，请先自尽。然后我会效劳。于是赖政转身面对太阳落下的西方。他连续十次诵念佛陀的名字。然后他创作诗歌。当他创作这些诗句时，他念了出来。这棵被遗忘的树，在流逝的岁月里从未开花。
And now that the end has come, no thought but turns to sorrow. And then wishing to avoid any accusation of cowardice, he takes his sword and he takes his sword and he drives it into his belly and he slices open his abdomen, cutting left and right. And this is the most painful suicide imaginable. And now at last the servant is willing to behead him. So the servant draws out his sword, cuts off Yorimasa's head, and then that done, he ties it to a heavy stone, carries it to the banks of the Uji, and drops it into the river. And this will serve subsequent generations of samurai as the absolute paradigm of what is called sepulchal, belly slitting. It's not the first, but it is the model that everyone from this point on will emulate.
现在结局已到，思绪只转向悲伤。然后为了避免任何怯懦的指责，他拿起剑，他拿起剑，把它刺入自己的肚子，他切开了腹部，左右切割。这是可以想象的最痛苦的自杀。现在仆人终于愿意斩首他了。于是仆人拔出剑，砍下了赖政的头，然后做完这些，他把它系在一块沉重的石头上，带到宇治河岸边，把它扔进河里。这将作为后代武士的绝对范例，即所谓的“切腹”。这不是第一次，但它是从这一点开始每个人都会效仿的模式。
This is the moment that establishes the template. Yeah, it's the absolute archetype. And I think the luster of this death combined with, with the heroism of the Uji Bridge makes the battle of the Uji Bridge a kind of Japanese equivalent of the Battle of Thermopylae in Greek history. So it's a defeat that isn't just a defeat. The kind of the glamour and the glory of the defeat gives it the sheen of something approaching almost a victory. And in Isu, when news of this is brought to Yoritomo, the head of the Minatomo
这就是建立模板的时刻。是的，它是绝对的原型。而且我认为这种死亡的光彩，加上宇治桥的英雄主义，使宇治桥之战成为希腊历史中温泉关战役的日本版本。所以这是一场不仅仅是失败的失败。失败的魅力和荣耀赋予了它一种接近胜利的光泽。在伊豆，当这个消息传到源氏氏族首领赖朝那里时，
clan, he is emboldened to raise the white banner of his clan in open defiance of Kiamori. And by late autumn, he has successfully rallied all the Lords of Kanto, so the great plain behind him. He's got their backing. And he has also established a capital in a place called Kamakora, which is a natural fortress on the coast of Kanto, where his father had always had his main base. And then the following month, after he's done this, a Tyra advance on Canto is beaten off in a completely farcical fashion. I mean, it's kind of as ludicrous as the defence of the Uji Bridge had been heroic.
他受到鼓舞，举起氏族的白旗，公开反抗清盛。到了深秋，他成功地聚集了关东所有的领主，也就是他身后的关东大平原。他得到了他们的支持。他还建立了一个叫镰仓的地方作为首都，这是关东海岸的一个天然堡垒，他父亲一直把那里作为主要基地。然后在他做完这件事后的下个月，平氏对关东的进攻以一种完全荒谬的方式被击退。我的意思是，它就像宇治桥的防御一样荒谬，而宇治桥的防御是英雄般的。
So what happens is that the Tyra advancing along the road that winds around the mountains that will take them to Canto. And they meet with a Minamoto force that has been sent to block its path. Night falls. and in the darkness a squad of Minamoto samurai kind of head out from their positions to make a night attack on the Tyra. And as they're heading towards the Tyra positions, they disturb a flock of geese which rise up very, very clamorously kind of honking and beating their wings. And they fly directly into the lines of the Tyra. And the Tyra are thrown into a massive panic, turn on their heels and flee. And this is humiliating as the death of Yorimasa had been glorious.
所以发生的事情是，平氏沿着绕过山脉通往关东的道路前进。他们遇到了一支被派去阻挡其道路的源氏部队。夜幕降临。在黑暗中，一小队源氏武士从他们的阵地出发，对平氏进行夜袭。当他们向平氏阵地前进时，他们惊动了一群鹅，它们非常、非常喧闹地鸣叫并拍打翅膀。它们直接飞进了平氏的队伍。平氏陷入了巨大的恐慌，转身逃跑。这和赖政的死亡一样令人羞辱，而赖政的死亡是光荣的。
And it's very, very bad publicity for the Tyra and particularly for Kiomori, who is appalled because he realizes that it's actually not going to be possible for him to snuff out this rebellion as he'd been expecting to. That he now faces a full-blown war with Yoritomo, the Minamoto captain, who was the very man whose life he had once spared, you know, back when he'd been a 13-year-old boy. Should never have done it. He was too soft. He's too soft and he's going to pay the price. I think he does feel that he'd been too soft. And so he is, in a way, because of that, he reacts with incredible brutality. When he needs to be brutal, he's perfectly willing to be brutal.
这对平氏，特别是对清盛来说，是非常、非常糟糕的宣传，他感到震惊，因为他意识到他实际上不可能像他预期的那样扑灭这场叛乱。他现在面临与源氏队长赖朝的全面战争，而赖朝正是他曾经饶过一命的人，你知道，在他还是个13岁男孩的时候。本不该这么做。他太软弱了。他太软弱了，他将付出代价。我想他确实觉得他太软弱了。所以，在某种程度上，因为这个，他以令人难以置信的残忍做出反应。当他需要残忍时，他完全愿意残忍。
And so he is brutal now. And he stamps out any hint of rebellion in the lands around Kyoto. And the people who are treated with a particular savagery are the monks of Nara. These were the guys that Prince Michiito had been hoping to get. And they had actually kind of raised the banner of revolt against Kiamori. And so Kiamori sends his son ahead of a great squad of samurai, and they slaughter thousands of monks in Nara. Cutting the heads off again? Yeah, there's more head cutting.
所以他现在很残忍。他镇压了京都周围土地上的任何叛乱迹象。受到特别野蛮对待的人是奈良的僧人。这些人就是以仁王希望得到的人。他们实际上已经向清盛举起了反叛的旗帜。于是清盛派他的儿子率领一大队武士，他们在奈良屠杀了数千名僧人。又在砍头吗？是的，还有更多的砍头。
They're tossed into gutters and ditches. Smoke filled the heavens, we're told. The sky was flame, and many of the holiest and most ancient shrines in the holy, of Japan are utterly incinerated. And we're told no disaster approaching this one can ever before have struck the teaching. So that's the teaching of the Buddha. Thank you. So Keir Mori, if you remember, he had had that interaction with the fox. And the fox had said, basically, all your wishes will come true. But as your death approaches, so all your, everything you have achieved will begin to crumble into dust.
他们被扔进阴沟和沟渠里。我们被告知，烟雾弥漫了天空。天空是火焰，日本神圣的许多最神圣和最古老的神社被彻底焚毁。我们被告知，在此之前，没有任何灾难能像这次这样打击教义。所以那是佛陀的教义。谢谢。所以清盛，如果你还记得，他曾与那只狐狸有过互动。狐狸说，基本上，你所有的愿望都会实现。但随着你死亡的临近，你所取得的一切都将开始化为尘埃。
And do you think he's got that sort of at the back of his mind as the war intensifies? Indisputably, because all kinds of presentiments of impending ruin had been visiting him. And these are described in the tale of the heikie. So there's a time we're told when Ki-a-Mori saw, and I quote, an enormous face of full bay-wide peering into the room where he lay. That would really unsettle you. I really would. I was so weird and sinister.
你认为随着战争的加剧，他心里有这个想法吗？毫无疑问，因为各种即将毁灭的预感一直困扰着他。这些在《平家物语》中有描述。所以我们被告知，有一次清盛看到，我引用，一张巨大的脸，有一湾宽，窥视着他躺着的房间。那真的会让你不安。真的会。太奇怪和阴险了。
And then another morning, he opens the doors onto his garden, and he finds it piled high with skulls. And we're told a mountain of skulls now suddenly crammed with living eyes, all of them training on Lord Kiamori and a blinking glare. It's very studio gibbly, I think. Kind of very particular quality of horror. And on both occasions, Kiya Mori responds with his customary sang foie. He's not a man to panic at a kind of giant face leering in a disquality.
然后另一个早晨，他打开通往花园的门，发现那里堆满了头骨。我们被告知，一座头骨山现在突然挤满了活生生的眼睛，所有这些眼睛都盯着清盛，闪烁着眩光。我想这非常吉卜力工作室。有一种非常独特的恐怖感。在这两种情况下，清盛都以他惯常的冷静做出回应。他不是一个会在某种巨大的脸从窗户窥视或花园里满是头骨时感到恐慌的人。
in through a window or a garden full of skulls. And the visions do fade away. But then in the wake of the burning of Nara, it's evident that his doom is now coming upon him because he begins to burn with the hottest temperature in world history. That's a big claim. In all world history. In all of world history, nothing compares with the temperature that Lord Kiyamori suffers. So we are told his only words, once his temperature gets him, were hot, hot. and he tries to calm it down by stepping into icy springs, and the water in these icy springs just steams, boils and turns to steam. He must have been properly hot.
幻象确实消失了。但在焚烧奈良之后，很明显他的末日即将来临，因为他开始发着世界历史上最高的热度。这是一个很大的说法。在所有世界历史上。在所有世界历史上，没有什么能比得上清盛所遭受的温度。所以我们被告知，一旦他的温度上来，他唯一的话就是，热，热。他试图通过走进冰冷的泉水来冷静下来，而这些冰冷泉水中的水只是冒着蒸汽，沸腾并变成蒸汽。他一定是非常热。
Yeah, well, no one can approach him. And he's kind of lying on his bed, kind of writhing in agony for a month. And then finally, his wife kind of braves the heat, you know, because kind of risking being incinerated by it. Yeah, he's like the human torch from the Fantastic Four. And she says, you know, what's your dying wish, my lord? now that you're on your deathbed. His dying wish has to be said, it doesn't seem to me particularly Buddhist.
是的，嗯，没有人能靠近他。他躺在床上，痛苦地挣扎了一个月。最后，他的妻子冒着热气，你知道，因为冒着被烧焦的危险。是的，他就像《神奇四侠》里的人类火炬。她说，你知道，你临终的愿望是什么，主公？现在你已经在临终床上了。他的临终愿望必须说，在我看来，这对他来说并不是特别佛教。
He says, never mind building me temples and pagodas, never mind pious prayers for me once I am gone. No, I want Yoritomo's head off and hung before my grave. That is the only commemoration I wish. I respect that. He's sticking to his guns. He certainly is. And so he dies pledging his family, the Tyra, to undying war with the Minamoto, and war, sure enough, is what both the Tyra and the Minamoto are going to get.
他说，别管给我建什么寺庙宝塔，也别管我死后为我做的虔诚祈祷。不，我要赖朝的人头，把它挂在我的墓前。那才是我想要的唯一纪念。我很敬佩这一点。他坚持自己的立场。确实如此。于是他发誓让他的家族平氏与源氏进行永无止境的战争，而战争，毫无疑问，正是平氏和源氏都将要面对的结局。
And this war is the most epic, the most famous war in the entire history of the samurai. It is the great samurai war. Speaking just for myself, I cannot wait to find out what happens next. And actually, members of the rest of history club, our own samurai war band, can find out what happens next right away. And if you want to join them, and in fact, if you want to hear, the next two episodes after that in the series, if you'd like to hear those right now, ad-free, and you'd love a load of other Japanese-style benefits, then I would suggest going to the Restis History.com and signing up, and you too can follow the way of the samurai.
这场战争是整个武士历史上最史诗、最著名的一场战争。这就是伟大的武士战争。就我个人而言，我迫不及待地想知道接下来会发生什么。事实上，历史俱乐部其余的成员，也就是我们自己的武士战争小分队，可以立刻知道接下来会发生什么。如果你想加入他们，事实上，如果你想现在就听到这个系列接下来的两集，而且是无广告的，并且你还想获得许多其他日本风格的福利，那么我建议你去Restis History.com注册，你也可以追随武士之道。
And Dominic, am I not right that there is an excellent new newsletter? I can't believe I didn't mention it. So a lot of people have been saying that the new newsletter is comparable probably only to the tale of Genji and the pillowbook in terms of elegance of composition, in terms of the wealth of information, the information about medieval Japan, and just the sort of general sense of beauty and poise and sort of beautiful balance to it. Yes. That's certainly the feedback that I've had about the newsletter. Well, there is actually an extract from the tale of the hakei, if you're interested to know what it sounds like. There's an interview with the curator of the British Museum show. There's all kinds
多米尼克，我没说错吧，有一份非常棒的新时事通讯？真不敢相信我竟然没提它。很多人都说，这份新的时事通讯在文采的优雅程度、信息的丰富程度、关于中世纪日本的信息，以及那种整体的美感、从容和优美的平衡感方面，恐怕只有《源氏物语》和《枕草子》能与之媲美。是的，这确实是我收到的关于时事通讯的反馈。嗯，如果你想知道《平家物语》听起来是什么样，里面确实有一段摘录。还有对大英博物馆展览策展人的采访。有各种各样
of tremendous benefits, isn't it? Right. On that bombshell, Tom, al-a-a-a-a-a-zamas, and goodbye, everybody. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
巨大的好处，不是吗？好的。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，再见，大家再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。